personne à nouveau sous les bombes ce
dimanche c'est le centre même de la
ville qui a été visé
les fenêtres se font envolées je me suis
assis sur le lit et j'ai été projeté en
arrière à cause de l'ombre de chocs au
total selon le gouverneur 54 attaques
ont été menées dans cette région reprise
il y a plus d'un mois par l'armée
ukrainienne
personne ne réalise qu'il y a une ligne
de front ici et que cela empire chaque
jour nous ne partirons pas d'ici
personne ne nous attend et nous n'avons
pas d'argent pour partir de toute façon
côté russe la guerre se poursuit plus au
nord à Belgorod ou des frappes
ukrainiennes ont fait plusieurs blessés
selon le gouverneur de la ville alors
que Vladimir Poutine doit se rendre en
Biélorussie ce lundi Vladimir Zelenski a
pris la parole déterminée à ne rien
lâcher la protection de notre frontière
tente avec la Russie qu'avec la
Biélorussie et notre priorité permanente
nous nous préparons à tous les scénarios
de défense possible le président
ukrainien a également déclaré que son
pays tenait la ville de backmouth depuis
plusieurs semaines cette ville située
dans l'est de l'U est l'un des fronts
les plus violents de la guerre
direction la Chine